we begin with this Fox News Alert
tonight Reckless aggression in the skies
a U.S Reaper drone operating over
international waters above the Black Sea
down by a Russian fighter jet two of
them had two su-27 aircraft they flew
dangerously close to our unmanned drone
now Putin's thugs then dumped fuel on
our drone several times before then
finally ramming its propeller and then
sending our 14 million dollar aircraft
into the sea below now some reports
claim that the Collision was not
intentional and that the Russian Pilots
they were just provocative and
incompetent amateurs make no mistake
this was no accident and I can guarantee
you that Vladimir Putin personally
signed off on this military aggression
now here's her very own Jennifer Griffin
with Senator Mike rounds take a look
I'd just like to get your reaction to
what happened today in the Black Sea
pissed off I mean let's just be honest
about this for a second the report
coming out of our government is that
this was an unprofessional act and
environmentally unsound I'm sorry folks
they shot down a United States war plane
they took it out of action and that's
the response we get back so yeah not
very happy about it and the bottom line
is we cannot allow that to happen that's
right we can't allow this to happen
Russia and Putin's hostility and
aggression against our country the
United States has now reached a
dangerous New Height now tonight the
question is this what will your
President Joe Biden do is he going to
offer maybe another waiver for the
nordstream 2 pipeline put more sanctions
in place Putin's not going to care
because he's selling his energy and
getting Filthy Rich he's selling it to
China the rest of the world and making a
fortune in large part because your
President Joe Biden has artificially
reduced the world supply of of energy by
giving up on almost all domestic energy
production last year the Saudis they
made a whopping record
161 billion dollars in profit from oil
and gas because we artificially reduce
the world's Supply because Joe is giving
in to the climate alarmist cult now Joe
is importing oil from another hostile
regime Venezuela and we're going to now
make their Thug dictator Rich so again I
ask what Joe are you going to do Joe
Biden you are the president of the
United States you're the
commander-in-chief this sad reality is
it looks like you will do nothing Russia
sat back and they watched the Chinese
five balloon they watched the fly over
Alaska's guys down the west coast of
Canada over our missile silos in
beautiful Montana down to Missouri and
Kansas over to Kentucky and then out to
the Carolinas then you decided to shoot
it out of the sky after the Communist
Chinese got all the intelligence they
could ever want you finally shoot it
down and then you overreact and you
shoot down three unidentified they still
have not told us what these objects are
but we believe one was likely a hundred
dollar hobby Club balloon and they spent
a four hundred thousand dollar
Sidewinder missile to shoot that out of
the sky now other Chinese spy balloons
were spotted near U.S territories all
over the globe and green space lasers
from a mysterious Chinese satellite
beaming down around Hawaii and let's not
forget about China's threats to reunify
with our Ally Taiwan which are now
reaching a fever pitch never mind the
Communist Chinese flying over their
fighter jets over Taiwan airspace on a
regular basis then if you want to really
add insult to injury China is now
demanding that we apologize for all of
their hostile Behavior Joe what are you
going to do meanwhile the mullers of
Iran they are now enriching uranium at a
record pace and we are told they are on
track to get their nuclear weapon that
is a clear and present danger to the
entire world and all of this comes as a
new Access of Evil is emerging between
these three top geopolitical foes
China's dictator Chi is now scheduled to
hold a very rare but significant meeting
with Putin in Moscow so how much you
want to bet it'll probably be trading
jokes about just how pathetically weak
America's president is this is beyond
embarrassing this is danger danger to
the Safety and Security of the entire
world and add to all of this China just
brokered a big new energy deal between
what former sworn enemies Iran and Saudi
Arabia this this too is a big deal
remember under Donald Trump remember we
had the Strategic Alliance I never
thought I'd see it my lifetime it was
the United States it was Israel the
Saudis the Egyptians the jordanians and
the Emirates they all United against
Iranian hegemony in the region under
Biden that Alliance is clearly dead now
the world's most hostile actors are
aligning while Joe forces the military
to what was now spending three billion
dollars on climate change every year we
should be building bombs uh Jets and
missiles and ships Joe America's enemies
are on the move they are aggressive they
are consolidating power they're creating
Partnerships and alliances that the
world better take note of while Joe
Biden your president is asleep at the
wheel Russia and Putin took out an
American drone over international waters
and I ask again Joe Biden what are you
going to do if you do nothing they will
be more emboldened and it will only get
worse from here and by the way Joe the
Mexican president is now boasting that
his country is safer than the U.S
apparently everyone on earth now knows
that they can walk all over Joe Biden
and they know that most cities and towns
have adopted this defund dismantle no
bail law Insanity of the Democratic
Socialist Party hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else